i feel like there's a world where this
like let's be conservative i feel like
there's a
like this is very clearly a 10 million a
year thing that makes 2 million in
profit
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to
dude there's like a picture in the
background that is just getting my
attention so much
that crooked there's like a crooked
picture you see it
yeah yeah there's a whole subreddit
called like uh
i forget what it's exactly called but
it's about like minor things that are
just slightly off like what were they
thinking it's like
mildly like there's mildly interesting
that's probably mildly irritating or
something like that
no it's called mildly infuriating did
you
did you just guess that well i know
about mildly interesting so
yeah uh anyway what's going on justin um
do you know you know what you're getting
into like do you know what we're what we
do
yeah no i know a good bet all right good
so
you uh we'll just do like a really quick
intro but you uh
you've done a bunch of stuff i've known
you since 2013 i think right
yeah i think actually a little earlier
when you were doing the room
we both had roommate businesses and he
we just became friends he moved to sam
you you moved to san francisco i ended
up introducing him
or no he met one of the girls a girl he
dated for a long time
in the elevator on his way up to our
meeting who was my co-worker
and so we just ran in like the circle of
friends for years that's pretty good so
you get the number
in the elevator or what was the
elevators not it's only a two floor
you're
on the second floor right so that's not
too long
it was a fast it was a fast close yeah
how'd that happen tell me about it
yeah do you want me to share this thing
i'm happy yeah
yeah i mean we met and this girl walked
into an elevator and i was like
just making a joke she was i think like
maybe a tiny bit drunk and tried to hit
a button but there were no buttons in
the elevator it's one of those fancy
ones that like
you walk into and the attendant sends
you somewhere and so i just
started sort of making fun of her for
that and in the
several story ride with like two other
stops um
i was like hey we should hang out and
then we hung out at um at sam's
apartment list party and
shane numbers and have been friends
hence amazing uh okay and sam did you
did you know that justin was going to go
on to do great things at the time did
you spot that early or no was he just
another dude
yeah well we were both schemin we were
only 22 i think when we met
that was a while ago and he um he had
this roommate thing and i had a roommate
thing and i think anyone who ever
started that's like
there's like three things that you start
right when you graduate college and that
like that's like one of them and so they
never work out well
like they're never that good so anyway
by the way there's three are like
music discovery uh why is it so hard to
find new music
that we could solve that problem uh it's
roommate roommate discovery
is another one and then food delivery
it depends who you're and then like or
like college craigslist
yeah exactly local local craigslist
sometimes it's to-do list or sometimes
if it's like your first time commuting
you're like
if you're i know this for engineers i've
met like 10 engineers that all made the
same thing first which was
basically like a bus tracking software
that tells them when the bus is coming
because they're just like you're so
tired of the unpredictable like is it
seven minutes
more or less and they're like i need to
make an app for this well so
yeah we were both doing that and i knew
i mean whatever we
that was a stepping stone for both of us
and then he
started um you co-wrote a book with a
guy
or no you you sold a company or you
joined a company somehow you were
working with my friend terry
and their whole business was buying and
selling stuff and that was like
pretty successful i believe and then you
also started working on writing this
book called traction
with this duckduckgo guy gabe is his
name right
yep exactly and then it was and then he
was doing udemy courses and i was like
yeah i mean we're all like schemers he
had like airbnbs
and i think you did you buy cars and
rent them to uber people
uh no my roommate was doing that i was
looking at doing it but decided it was a
miserable business so didn't end up
doing it
and we were so we were always doing
stuff we had you had a udemy course i
probably was selling some type of
information stuff and then he started
this thing called kettle and fire
which first of all like i thought it was
so stupid on
so many capacities or so many uh places
so first i was like he was like i want
to start like selling like
this uh like hard good i'm like bro like
we work in the internet why would you
ever want to like
start like a goods thing then he was
like it's gonna be food and i'm like
your kid like why would you ever do that
then he said it was bone broth and i was
like
bone broth people drink bone broth and
then this was like before like this
whole like
i don't even think the word d to c was a
was a thing and so
obvi i mean i thought it was the dumbest
thing ever and i was wrong right like
it's been it's been a smashing success
and he started this kettle and fire
thing and it's quite big you've also
started uh my neighbor sean is this guy
named anthony i don't know who did it
first one of you guys like had this
thing
called uh perfect keto where you're
selling keto products and then you guys
like
combine you so we we partnered up on it
basically we
i was like running kettle and fire and
as i do sometimes
looking for like another side hustle
thing to start on the side
uh and he had another business that was
in the supplement space but
the two of us were just like hey we
should work on a small side project
together
make something that does 20 grand a
month and like once we hit that
threshold we'll like blow it all on a
ridiculous trip to japan
and that was like the whole goal of the
business uh pretty big right
yeah i mean we we thought it would take
like a year or two to get to 20 grand a
month and we did it in the first like 45
days it was insane
and then kettle and fire is like a big
thing too you guys like i think
you raised money or did you sell a
portion of it
yeah so kettle and fire we uh we raised
money we bootstrapped for the first 18
months
raised a tiny bit of money less than a
million dollars ran in another like 16
months and then decided that
the the opportunity was big enough that
it made sense for us to raise so we
raised
16 million dollars in 2018 about half of
that went to
secondary and the other half went to
like actually putting money into the
business
so i've heard a number that either
kettle and fire or perfecto or both did
a hundred million in revenue i don't
know if that's a cumulative lifetime
number i don't know if that's an annual
number
is this a public number or is this what
can you tell me about this because that
was a big number i was yesterday
and i'm a customer yeah like six of your
bone broths
uh you know sitting in my pantry right
now yeah i really like it i love that
there's one flavor i really like and i
feel like i never get it
in any store and then i'm like all right
let me try these other five and see if
any of them can match that one i really
love
what's the one that you're super into uh
i don't know which one it's it's like
the top it's like i think it's like one
of the thai
lime yeah i think it's either the tom
yum or one of the other ones like it's
like this like a thai
curry type flavor and yeah yeah yeah
that's one of my favorites
yeah and some of those by the way are
nasty but some of them are really good
and so i'm like it's like you know those
like
when you get a pack of cards you're like
looking for a hologram like a
holographic charizard inside and then
you get a squirtle that's how i feel
about kettle and fire i know this is not
common but
that's just my personal experience with
so far
thanks man i'll take that as a
compliment okay but back
back to the business side so uh i was a
customer but i was shocked when i heard
that 100 million number what is that
number
yeah so that's not cumulative uh you
know we we stopped sort of
disclosing revenue numbers recently but
i can say in 2019 like the two
businesses combined did north of 100.
gotcha and it's what is perfect keto so
i know kettle and fire what's perfect
keto
yeah so perfect keto is a line of
supplements and food products for people
interested
in lowering their carb and sugar intake
and so we we have like a clean label
line of
foods and supplements for people on a
ketogenic diet or who just like want to
eat fewer carbs and no sugars
gotcha and are you keto and sean the guy
who started it by or
his partner is literally my next-door
neighbor yeah but you also say
everyone's your neighbor so i never know
what to believe and then i came to visit
you and you drove me around you're like
that's where this guy lives that's where
this person lives that's where this
person lives and now i
now i believe you but if somebody's
listening literally like
wait he said his neighbor is neville
then he said his neighbor is
the guy who made the ice barrel thing
that we talked about last time
then he said his neighbor's the student
loan guy then he said
it's this other thing and student
student loan hero guy
and i are the same guy so they live like
he lives like
20 houses down anthony literally lives
direct like
uh like 30 feet from me right uh
yeah like literally right so the con i
guess the context here is
you knew justin lucy um and i've never
met justin no i did not not lose
well okay and um intimately and
you've done two things i think that are
really interesting one is the perfect
keto stuff and carolyn fire basically
building a brand
that's been pretty damn successful and
then the other is
you write content and i want to actually
talk about some of the content stuff you
write so
you have the book traction that's a good
book but on your blog there's one blog
post that i remember
it's been sent to me several times so i
know other people like it too
so let's start there if you're cool with
it which is you have this side hustle
post on on your blog and i'm assuming
this is probably one of your more
popular blog posts is that right
yeah definitely and you basically
outline that you've done a bunch of side
hustles and then you have like kind of
like you break it down as like there's
these four types of side hustles so
can you give us kind of like give us the
side hustle bit
uh here which is like and if you scroll
all the way down to that sheet you're on
you'll see your
yeah which is basically like what are
the side hustles you've done all right
kind of
how do you think about side hustles and
then break people break those four down
for people
totally yeah so the reason that i got
into this is
uh when sam and i met you know the two
of us were like we want to do this
entrepreneurship thing
but in in many ways it's actually a lot
easier and like emotionally
uh bearable to start a company if you
have just like income coming in that's
covering your expenses
and so when i moved to san francisco you
know this the city is super expensive
and so i started like doing a bunch of
side hustles just to try and make income
that would give me
the freedom to like spend my time trying
to launch a company that would
really create a lot of like equity value
and sort of like life-changing
um you know financial freedom and so
when i what i did when i moved to sf i
like started airbnb
our place we at one point yeah this was
2013.
we had like the number third like the
third ranked airbnb in san francisco
and so we were uh we were like renting
out either our living room
most nights or uh you know over summers
we'd rent it out for like
15 18 grand a month and then we just and
we were paying three grand a month for
the spot
so like that was incredible at the time
and we'd just travel
and then launched like udemy courses
there was a period where i was buying
motorcycles that were on craigslist in
oakland and selling them in san
francisco because there was like an
arbitrage there
so i was just doing a bunch of random
random stuff
and so when i wrote this article so many
people that i've talked to
were like you know i want to understand
how to make side income and how to think
about this stuff
um and so i just kind of like broke down
like the the different sorts
in my mind like the four kinds of
businesses that you can start
as a side hustle um you know some of
these that i've done actually ended up
being more
more real businesses but like do you
want me to talk through the categories
and kind of whatever you also had a good
disclaimer which is like look
first things first accept that what
you're doing is not meant to be
the next facebook it's not meant to be a
startup it's like you're trying to make
money you're trying to get some
profitable cash flow from a business
quickly
without a ton of like you know without
waiting seven years for this thing to
pay off so like first
let's call it what it is all right let's
call a spade a spade is i thought
an important disclaimer and then you had
these four four groups uh so
let's run through them and then sam you
tell me if you've also done any in these
categories yeah
totally yeah i mean i think truly if
you're mark zuckerberg or like a
collison brother like
[__] raise money do like the the
massive thing that you're working on
i just think for most people
entrepreneurship is a means to an end
and that end is like a lifestyle that
people are trying to create
and so the more that you can like create
that and the faster you get financial
freedom
i just think that's a useful thing for
more people to have in general
um so the the four like kinds of side
hustles that
that i talked about in my blog post um
the first one that i talk about is like
buying an existing asset
basically you can look at like what's an
existing asset that you could try and
purchase
leverage your skills connections
resources whatever
to upgrade that you know make it more
cash flow positive make it do better
whatever
and then you get to capture the value
created by upgrading that asset
i did this with like sam i'm sure you
guys could do this if you bought an
email newsletter
you know you know how to run that better
buy it for a million bucks
improve it you could probably sell it
for you know three to five a couple
years later
yeah i was um my friend ramone bought
something that i had a
small part of and it was a software very
small software app that when we bought
it maybe it was doing 20 000 a month and
all we did was we
doubled the price of the product and it
doubled the revenue
amazing and you did that too didn't you
own a or you bought a thing called fomo
right yeah yeah so a partner and i
bought a shopify app called fomo
uh it was doing 14k a month at the time
we bought it uh you know we bought it
uh we paid less than 400 i'll say that
less than 400 000. yeah which was like a
super good multiple
yeah you didn't roll some equity down
right so you get seller financing or
what you do
yeah so we had a really like the guy
basically wanted out it was a single
founder
and we were like hey we know how to
market we have connections we can like
really help grow this thing
and so we bought 85 percent of the
business uh we
bought it and then we were basically
like we're gonna buy this
and pay you in monthly chunks for the
next 20 months um
and so every like month for 20 months
we use the revenue that we were making
from fomo to make our payment to him
and like my partner and i basically came
out of pocket zero dollars to acquire
this asset
we were obviously working on running it
we like had to throw in i think it ended
up being five grand each
to pay the developers the first couple
months but um but yeah i mean it was
like an incredible acquisition how big
is it now
now it does about 95 grand a month
sounds like a good deal to me
yeah it's a good deal i mean it's good
deal for everyone the guy like has
gotten his time back he's started other
companies in the interim and like
when we exit this thing he'll make
probably more than he would have made
on the exit than you know had he
continued to run this for the last three
years
and with no headache it's like a nice
thing so you're talking about buy
so category one buying an asset this can
be uh
a house that you airbnb it can be a
internet company that you just
you know you do what sam did you go in
the code you push you know control
f you find the price and then you change
the number to double which is like sam's
genius or what you did was
you know who i learned that from was
terry you're i don't know if she was
your boss or what
but she taught me how to do it how to
find the price point
well she was like she was like look the
whole thing is that engineer-led
businesses typically are priced poorly
and if you just double the price
uh it works right and she was like
double the price and then find out which
emails uh urls are being used a bunch of
times so for example if you have like 18
people using
uber.com contact the hr department or
whoever the procurement and like
sell enterprise she kind of like taught
me the stuff that uh
justin's old company was doing yeah
exactly so i so i ended up
i really like this buy an asset thing i
think sometimes you have to have money
other times you can sell our finance but
we ended up doing this too with an
apartment building in in vegas
where we bought a 14 unit apartment
building could put it all on airbnb
uh basically like tripled the cash flow
and then sold it 18 months later
for you know 70 more than what we paid
by the way in the blog post you had a
couple examples i think are useful
we don't have to go too much into them
but you were like uh you talked about
this thing which is like okay if you
know you have the skills to like improve
the value of the asset so for airbnb you
were like all right
to get more airbnb bookings like you
know first if it's not on airbnb we
should put it on airbnb
if it is on ibb we can like boost the
bookings by like these three things
right
uh put more and better photos up okay
easy anybody could do that but most
people haven't optimized that
second like instantly respond to every
inquiry so that we get a fast response
rate
the algorithm likes that and then the
last thing is like whatever like five
star reviews at the end or something
like that
and so you're like i can just take those
three levers and i can apply it to any
property now that isn't optimized for
airbnb
so if they think it's worth a hundred i
already know it's worth 120 because i
know i can just
do that playbook again on uh on on any
property
yeah exactly and that's like that
actually leads to the
sort of like the second bucket of side
hustles that i talk about which is
basically look at what is a marketplace
with existing demand
where you don't have to go out and find
the customer you just provide the supply
side stuff like
buying you know putting a property on
airbnb all i have to do is understand
how does the property like or how does
airbnb uh
dictate where i rank you know and what
does it want from me as a supplier
and then my [__] is gonna get booked up
uh like i don't actually have to go
find every individual customer that's
traveling to san francisco
that can rent our apartment because like
airbnb is doing that for me and you did
that with like uh was
you used to have a thing it was called
uh sql for programmers or what was it
called yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so basically
exactly so so i've done this on a couple
platforms like
amazon is a big one like a bunch of
people are starting fba businesses
but i sort of think that focusing on
up-and-coming platforms
where the supply side isn't crazy
competitive
is actually a really good place to start
where you could like when i when i was
um
when i launched my first udemy course
you know i filmed it literally over five
days
in my bedroom in san francisco no like
good quality no good editing it was just
like
it candidly like was not an amazing
course from a like student experience
standpoint but the content was good
uh but udemy was such an early platform
that i put it up there
and just by being literally the first
guy to talk about
here's how to learn sql as a marketer
like
that course sold i think like 60 grand
over the next couple years
um and to this day i still get like a
thousand dollars a month from that
course from udemy
which is absurd um and you know that was
all because like
here's an emerging platform they want
people creating stuff on the supply side
how do i create a course or whatever uh
that just like
can reach people who are already looking
for something on a platform um
and focus on that and i don't know if
you did this for that but uh
there's ways to basically figure out
what are people searching for so there's
like tools like ahrefs or whatever you
can figure out what what google searches
are
are people doing and in what volume but
uh even on
individual platforms there's ways to
figure it out like i know
i looked at this business to buy and it
was this girl selling a waist trainer
you know what a waste trainer is
yeah it's basically do you know what
this thing is it's like i had no idea
what this was before
um so it's basically like you know like
okay i'm gonna here's the here's the
mansplain to
there's three dudes talking about way
strainers all right so you know like if
you watch like pirates of the caribbean
or some any movie or
show that's like based in kind of like
olden times girls wear that like corset
it's like this super tight thing that
you're like you squeeze into this and
then you wear your dress on top so your
finger gets like
your stomach gets squeezed out and your
boobs get squeezed out like spanx or
something
it's like old-school spanx and so uh
what waste trainers are
are that it's basically like a cinch you
wear around your stomach
constantly and it makes you look good in
the moment but also the idea
is that it trains your your muscles or
your body to like
to to tighten up um because you kind of
have to keep it flexed in a way for it
to not like kind of be uncomfortable i
guess i don't know what the theory is
but that's my guess
and like the kardashians kind of like
you know talk about the stuff and it
kind of got a little more popular so
this girl
who was building this business i was
like cool so like what do you spend
every month in marketing
she's like oh like we don't spend
anything in marketing like so how do you
how are you growing so fast
she's like oh i just saw that on youtube
nobody was owning the keyword for waste
trainers
and like how to size one how to wear one
do they work
so she just created like the youtube
channel to be the answer to every search
question
about waste trainers on youtube and you
can go if you go search wasters right
now on youtube you'll find all her
videos amazing and so all her sales just
come just from that
and she was doing a few million dollars
a year of a revenue
a million dollars of profit per year
just through that one channel alone
amazing yeah good for her but yeah
i i think exactly what you're talking
about it's like find where people are
searching for
something and there's no supply there
and that's a really good place to focus
like when i
launched sql for marketers there was
literally almost nothing under the like
marketing like the technical marketing
or like the data analytics data driven
marketing
section for udemy and so it's like cool
if i put that up there
that seems like it'll it'll resonate and
do well uh which ended up being correct
and what are the third and fourth ones
yeah so the the third one is
uh basically like launch a unique
product in an area where you can buy
customers via paid acquisition
and again i think all of this is like
super important to remember that you're
not building facebook
you're just like if you look at google
adwords or waste trainers as you're
saying
and there's a gap there you can figure
out how to make a product
and your goal is not like make a hundred
million dollar business but make one
that does a million dollars a year
like there are almost infinite niches on
the internet where you can just
make a product buy some rough keywords
and just sell through in a category that
you know where you're like the first to
market or the first to do a really good
job what's an exam market that's what's
an example in that category that you've
seen either from yourself or a friend or
someone you've seen recently that's
doing that that model
yeah so there there's a company actually
that
is doing um that's like vests for dogs
but the vests are spiky so that coyotes
don't attack
your dog so you can turn the dog into a
pool
yeah exactly like you could put this
vest on a dog and then
it won't get eaten by coyotes because
it's got like spikes all over it
um so i mean what an incredible niche
product
uh you know that's definitely not gonna
like go public but
that could be an incredible business uh
and so that stuff like that i mean
honestly that's what um
that's what kettle and fire was going to
be when we first launched it i had no
idea
that bone broth would be such a
compelling category and
and the trend would take off like it has
like our plan was basically
we looked at we looked at google
searches and we were like
i think we can build a like 20 to 40
grand a month business so when you say
we looked at google searches what does
that mean in practical terms most people
have never done that so what
what what yeah fair so we we use like
google adwords keyword tool just to say
like which is that's
like discontinued now yeah i know now
you'd have to use uh
a refs or some hdm rush or something um
but at the time we used a tool that was
basically like
there's 2 000 people a month looking for
like buy bone broth online
and so if we can be the supplier that
will sell you bone broth online like
you know assuming we convert like even
10 of those people
200 orders 50 a month like you know that
that's a pretty material
uh side hustle and so that was like the
reason that we launched kettlebell yeah
google
is like you know it's like a magic lamp
and on one side you have all the
aladdin's out there making wishes and
then you just get to be the genie so
it's like
there are these tools that tell you
here's the wishes people are entering
into this magic box
they're just hoping for something and if
you notice that exactly
that's more people than i would have
expected saying this thing or asking
this question or wanting this thing
and you go search for it and you're like
wow these results suck uh okay how do i
just become the top result for that
thing
and so you thought you thought kettle
and fire would do that so give me a
sense of how long did it take for you to
get from
idea like seeing that keyword and being
like oh maybe we could do this to
actually making like i don't know a
thousand dollars a month how long was
that process for you
yeah so the process took about a year
most of it was because i'd never done
a physical product before and so it was
like just bumbling around in the dark
like trying to find someone that could
make this stuff
had a bunch of false starts but it took
us basically 12 months to
uh to go from like hey i think this is
an opportunity to actually having
product in box
but once we had product in box you know
we did over 20 grand our first month
that we were live
so and you um you are you the ceo
of cattle and fire i am yeah you've got
like three we're gonna talk about
this other thing that you're thinking
about doing how are you balancing all
this time
it's a good question uh i i honestly
i've never had a good answer for this
i just like balancing it well uh okay
i mean some of these things like perfect
keto like i don't have a day-to-day role
in it anymore you know so i like
co-founded it but i've completely
stepped away
uh one of the things that at kettle and
fire that i think
i'm proud of that we've done really well
is like we have a phenomenal team
and so to that to that extent i get to
work on stuff
that only i can do uniquely well like
writing
long 15 page posts about how beef is
actually like not bad for the
environment and
[__] like this that i'm kind of
interested in but a lot of the day to
day is handled by like the team that
we've
built over the last you know five five
plus years
so i really like am in control of my
time in general
partner with a guy like anthony or
whoever you're partnering with
and you aren't doing how many of these
things do you have right now where you
have your hands in
roughly right now like five
probably okay and so but there's one
that's your day job right
yeah okay so for the other four when you
make these structures with people
so a guy like anthony or it doesn't have
to be him but the representative that
represents him
are you taking a draw from that business
at all or
are you just only going to pay yourself
if it sells
yeah so at this point i'm pretty focused
on like creating equity value
and so you know for an example like a
company i incubated
uh shirley wines it's like a
non-alcoholic wine company
we launched earlier this year i
recruited i like basically had the idea
tested it
validated it lined up supply chain hired
in the operator
um the operator and ceo he's taking a
salary and like
i probably won't get a dollar out of
that business uh
for until we eventually sell that
business or whatever happens with it
like i put in a bunch of my own money to
capitalize it and get it up and running
but i'm just like i'm not gonna
suck money out of that thing until uh
you know until we have a good outcome so
then really
the only thing you are not the only
thing i mean the thing you're bringing
the table is you are bringing a little
bit of cash
and also you're bringing some expertise
in your guide
yeah totally but it also like incubated
the whole idea that in that one
yeah yeah i mean i think it's basically
like
trying to create a a compelling
opportunity for someone
where you know someone can go instead of
going if someone wants to be a founder
ceo
today their options are like jump take
no salary for 12 to 18 months
hope they can figure out an idea and
raise money and do all that kind of
stuff
or like build a side hustle which is
again like a totally different skill set
that we're kind of talking about
and so with this one specifically like i
incubated the idea
had everything lined up validated that
it was big brought investors
and basically was like hey man if you
want to be a founder and ceo
you can just walk into this role you
take zero health care zero salary risk
uh and you're you're good like you're a
founder you have a ton of upside
you're this operating ceo we have
investors lined up it's a big
opportunity
like it sort of works for both parties
uh you know
when you um are you do you regret or
are you thankful that you raised money
for kettle and fire
oh definitely thankful i mean really
with yeah for sure i mean
with with kettle and fire in particular
like the business had grown
to a really meaningful amount and i
still had like
most of my net worth wrapped up in that
and so i think getting some secondary
was like personally really meaningful
um and it also meant that like i felt
more okay pushing for a bigger outcome
it also meant like i think i will
probably raise for most things that i do
going forward
or invest my own money just because the
caliber of the team that we were able to
hire around us
like what we were doing on a shoestring
budget versus what we could do after
was just night and day like we have an
amazing team
but amazing people are expensive and so
it's definitely like
made my life 100 times easier and more
enjoyable
getting to spend other people's money to
increase the value of my equity by
hiring amazing people it's like
that seems like a no-brainer to me in a
lot of ways uh
yeah when you explain that way it does
but if i was one of your investors and i
and you're doing all this other stuff
i'd be like what the [__] dude only do
this thing i just gave you money
yeah yeah i mean look it's it's
something that i had to work through
with our investors for sure
i was very upfront with it with them
about it was like look this is
my main focus um you know which was very
true
and it was definitely something to
manage around i also think though that
like
it's one of those things where as long
as the business is going well no one's
going to complain you know what i mean
but certainly if things went sideways
then it's then it's like
okay this is an easy area to point for
it's like elon can run tesla and spacex
and everyone's like wow he's amazing and
those businesses are amazing and then
jack does the same thing with twitter
and square and if twitter misses its
earnings it's like
off with his head how dare he you know
yeah he's a part-time ceo what the hell
were we thinking
and uh and so it's you know people are
pretty
they do uh what's called resulting
pretty hard in in that case
uh and you also did yeah yeah yeah you
also did a pretty fun experiment i i
don't know if this was a side hustle
or what would you call this where me and
sam were both guinea pigs in your uh
your continuous glucose monitoring trial
so you basically tweeted out yeah i was
sending them like i was sending them
like shirtless pics of myself like every
week yeah
typically that would include one photo
just him in his boxer's photo and
there's just a little p-spot
to show his body fat
and so you were doing this thing where
you were like hey i need like 20 people
or i don't know how many
maybe it's 40 people that you ended up
using yeah 50 people you were like hey
uh we're gonna do this experiment and
what you did was you sent us all
a levels uh glucose monitor and then
um continuous glucose monitor that we
just you know punctured into our arm
basically now okay that's measuring
and then you put us all in like a
whatsapp group and you're like hey
here's the idea and it was like
financial incentive i think it was like
you would pay us out every day that
we stayed in range and if we missed it
like you kept our money or something
like that
uh what was that experiment and what'd
you learn out of it man it was awesome
like
that that experiment was uh kind of like
many things
in my life i just had the idea tweeted
it immediately
and got such a strong response from
people we had like a wait list
yeah totally uh where i was like okay
now i gotta figure this out um
you know sam was texting me every day
being like this is sweet like i'm i'm
gonna
get all my [__] money back like
you're very into it i loved it
i was into it yeah it was super yes
awesome but yeah so
learned a ton man i mean one of the
craziest things i think was
just how well that incentive of like 25
a day
really worked for people to keep them
keep them honest like
you go through you know pay 950 bucks
for 30 days every day that you stay
under a barrier i like give you 25 bucks
back
and just that tiny little behavior like
incentive where
that brownie or whatever is not four
dollars but it's 29 dollars like
that uh i think that little incentive
goes a really long way and it's somewhat
competitive and all this
and so we have had with literally no
marketing you know we've we've filled up
50 person cohorts every month since
launching that in february
uh live yeah yeah people can still sign
up it's
wearablechallenge.com we've had one
person go through it seven times they've
lost
about 50 pounds it's like unbelievable
who
to see the results of this who's who's
running that
yeah so one of the guys in the first
cohort aaron got so excited about the
idea
i was like hey do you want to run with
this and so he
uh he's been running it it's amazing and
is that a business to you or what is
that
not really i mean we're kind of thinking
about like how to make it a business but
uh but it's actually a perfect example
of a side hustle like i will probably
make
you know somewhere between 20 and 30
grand this year from
doing right uh yeah when i fall maybe
more if sam joins and
blows a bunch of his glucose levels when
i saw that i was like
hey this is fun and uh it's kind of like
on brand for you because of the stuff
you
talk about in your businesses but then i
was also like oh this is a great
business because
everybody wants the outcome everybody
wants to eat right lose weight and
the biggest hack is not knowledge but
accountability and
i liked that you were coming at it from
an accountability point of view and i
actually think like
you know the company levels could do
something like this or
there's going to be a company that does
this right whatever weight watchers is
as a business model like
i haven't studied it i'm assuming you
have given what you do and
what this business is but could this not
be like weight watchers 2.0
i think it could be i mean it just it
would need someone to like run at it
really full time
but i do think that there's something
here i mean there's a couple companies
like
stick and like one other that i'm
forgetting where you can sort of like
bet money on um on different outcomes
and you know
i think that that sort of works i
actually think the really powerful part
of this is like
it's a cohort it's a challenge for a set
period of time and you lose money only
for that set period
right uh and so like i would love to
expand this and we're sort of
have some ideas in the in the hopper
about like what expanding it might look
like
but it's definitely not my like
full-time thing at all have you heard of
stick shawn
that's actually an interesting company
to buy i haven't been there in years but
when i used to go there it was
even when i went there like years ago it
was considered like old
so it's stick it's spelled stick but i
think there's two k's at the end right
yep and it's like a physical place
no it's a web stick.com but two k's at
the end
and uh is the website still all old and
janky looking
yeah okay so it was like old back then
when or in 2013 or 14 when i used to use
it and what you do is you enlist a
friend
uh to be the referee and then you create
i believe an anti-charity where you
uh select something that you hate and
then you upload money to it
and then if you fail at your challenge
your friend clicks a button and it
automatically goes to that place that
you hate
and i i think you can you there's a
varieties of the tim ferriss but talked
about this i think in four hour work
week and
i think it got popular from that yeah
yeah it it
did you think this company makes money
justin
i would imagine so i don't know how much
but
it could be it would it could be an
interesting thing to buy i mean it's
actually not that hard to replicate but
like if they already get
traffic it could be an interesting it
would be an interesting this would be an
interesting thing to buy and uh revamp
and make a little bit better
because i think they get a lot of
traffic when i um when we owned
toodledo there was this one guy an
author
uh i think he wrote a book uh getting
things done
what's called uh yeah
and he mentioned toodle-doo this app
that me and uh ramon
bought um and most of our customers came
to us
because they read about toodle-do like
it just mentioned them in like a
sentence or something in the book
and that's where most of the customers
came from and just because tim ferriss
mentioned
stick i bet that's where the the vast
majority of their customers come from
for sure yeah that's funny there was a
thing called jim pact too i don't know
if you guys
have seen that i don't know if it made
it it was like it came out five years
ago or something like that
but it was you would basically pledge
that you're gonna go to the gym with
some
some frequency and other people would
too and it basically i think what they
were doing was
like in your case you're the house
you're like the bank it's like i give
you the money then you pay me back
and in this case it was like it would
match you with somebody else
and uh if you ever didn't do your thing
your money would go to that person
uh if they did it and you didn't go your
money would go to them and if you both
went your money would be safe
and um and so you're like making a pact
that you would go to the gym for
you know some amount of frequency but i
do think there is something to this like
kind of financial incentive
accountability you know betting betting
on yourself betting on your habit
uh model that i think it's pretty cool
yeah i totally agree i mean
we're actually looking now at like could
you apply this to
run little you know health boot camps in
like la or austin or something like that
where you have 30 people 50 people opt
in will handle your meals we'll you know
we'll give you levels like we'll do all
this sort of stuff
and a more like premium offering that um
where it's like hey you're almost
guaranteed
to lose weight or get in better shape at
the end of this month that would for
sure work that's a little bit better
than my weight loss idea which is called
kidnap
where you just go and you take a person
and you bring them to the desert
uh in like vegas and you just kidnap
with two peas at the end
yeah kidnap sf or we'll call it hostage
and we just bring you to like a farm and
we just like it's like look you only
1500 calories a day do whatever you want
all day but like this is it
i love that um
can i imagine the refund rates would be
high on that well you know it'll be
guaranteed success um
so i want to get to some of these ideas
but i first want to ask you about
duckduckgo so you're friends with that
guy gabe right the guy who started it or
owns it and are you bullish on that
business because you're one of the few
people i know that has insight onto it
and i'm bit i look at their traffic
monthly like because they give out these
monthly updates
uh that does that is that business like
uh like kind of like an under the radar
thing do you think this is gonna take
over the world because that's kind of
how i feel
yeah i mean i i think it's it's crushing
like i think that you always see like
there's always like a counterpoint to
some massive trend or massive amount of
success like
you have like amazon taking over the
world but then you have shopify which is
crushing it and i think that
duckduckgo is like the counterpoint to
uh to like google and
you know privacy eroding across the
board all this sort of stuff
like i do think there's an opportunity
to be a
big tech company but with privates like
privacy is a core value rather than
uh you know selling ads to everyone and
so i think duckduckgo really has that
the opportunity to like be that company
and they have a lot of tailwinds that
are working in their favor at this point
um it's also crazy like gabe
he's been working on that company for
like 12 years five of those years
yeah i feel like it might be actually
um but like for a large chunk of that
time he was just a solo
founder building a search engine to
compete with google it's like
wow so they do north of 100 million in
revenue i believe
yeah i i believe do you i mean how like
i don't know if you i don't know if you
knew him during those early years but
like
did you know him at the beginning or now
not not the very very beginning but i
knew him when it was like
him and one other person working on
duckduck and so i'm guessing at that
point it wasn't
it wasn't a case where tim and one other
person and man it's crushing it it's
him and one other person and it's sort
of crawling forward um
yeah what were those kind like what were
your conversations like what was the
outlook
i mean i find it fascinating when people
work on these businesses that don't take
off right away and they stick with it
and then they need to either like the
world just changes or
they figure something out or just
compound slow slowly but then all of a
sudden it starts to take off like
what was that like they're the flat part
and then what do you think caused it to
grow
yeah i think that he was he was just
getting like small
bits of positive feedback from
communities like hacker news community
was like
duckduckgo is amazing for like stack
overflow searches or
you know x y and z very specific niche
sorts of searches
and then as you got good feedback from
those groups it's like okay let's invest
in product to make this a little better
a little better
and i think that after you know let's
call it 12 14 years he's been working on
this
the product has gotten a lot better but
also the like sort of
trend line of where big tech is going
has it's just gotten like way more
way more invasive and way more like
privacy is way more of a concern for
people today
especially as you're seeing a lot of the
censorship stuff and
you know some of this that's that's
happening in the big tech world right
now i think that
duckduckgo is like one of the few
companies that for
over a decade now has been like privacy
is one of our like core things
and they've built an incredibly complex
product uh
to compete with google that's just not
easy to spin up overnight
you know it's not a side hustle it's not
like the type of thing you or i can
build
with a couple hours a week uh over you
know a weekend
can we talk about can we go through some
of these ideas you want to start with
airbnb camping because i
uh you were texting me about this i uh
and i want to learn about it i just
looked at a house the other day
by the way uh down the street from my
house to buy for airbnb
i'll have to send you the numbers i
don't know if it it seems like a lot of
work for not a lot of
output we'll see yeah i think that's
probably true for a lot of airbnb right
now
i think the thing that is compelling to
me is like we talked earlier about new
platform stuff
like hip camp and some of these other
like camping platforms are exploding
and again i think if you could like
leverage capital
build up the supply side and provide
like
you know water toiletries like all the
basics
um in locations that people actually
want to camp at
you could build a pretty material
business and it again it like
may not be a 10 billion dollar business
but i think it would be a really solid
side hustle and cash flow asset and it
would require
a lot less um a lot less like management
and work than airbnb
because at the end of the day you're
[__] camping like sorry you know it's
not like
the the stove burner doesn't work or the
ac is off it's like
a lot of
[Laughter]
when you were doing this what numbers
were you bottling out
yeah so i was mainly modeling it from
like a noi basis
which is net operating income which is
like a term that's used a lot in real
estate
but basically i think that you could get
like 30 to 40 percent
cash on cash returns by following this
strategy that sounds like the greatest
thing ever why
why haven't you done it because i am
getting higher returns from my time
elsewhere
you know so whatever is this i would
love to find someone to run somebody
who's listening to this is like oh
i'm the perfect guy for this i i i love
camping i know i have camper i have a
camper myself
i'm in an area that's like a high demand
thing for hip camp or auto camp or
whatever
um yeah great you be the operator we'll
put up the cash we'll buy the rvs for
you and you run the thing and let's
split it so uh
email me sean seanpury.com and then i'll
loop in these guys and we will uh
we will fund your we'll fund a a small
rental business of
of campers if anybody's in the location
that does this
because that's a great that's a great
idea you're absolutely right they're
basically
tons of demand and they're supply
constrained and so if you just build out
more supply you're gonna get
bookings and you're gonna get great
returns off something yeah exactly and
it's one of those things that's like
that can scale really nicely these
platforms are here to stay like there's
a lot of venture dollars going into
making these more of a thing
i think that you could crush it on these
platforms is it something i want to do
full-time at this point in my career
no but do i think someone younger who
like cares about camping more than i do
could
really do well here like absolutely
right um okay great that's a great idea
what else you got
uh alcohol baby let's talk about that
yeah so
near to my heart as a as a as a
non-alcoholic beer drinker
yeah so you know a couple uh earlier
this year
launched a company that i talked about
shirley highshirtley.com s-u-r-e-l-y
um but we're basically like we saw so
much interest
going into the non-alcohor space bud
light bought three spots of the super
bowl
one was the seltzer spot the other was
for bud light the other was for bud zero
which is like
the non elk thing is so interesting and
like there's so much attention going
towards it
and we saw like a ton of really good
non-elk beers
with some really good like non-alex
spirits options and nothing in the wine
category
and so we decided to build the first
clean label really high quality
non-alcoholic wine brand and wine
company
uh hired like real wine making talent
and the like and we launched earlier
this year and it's going uh
going super well so how much did you uh
by the way
i want to brag i've been talking about
this [__] for like four years now
have a nice shawn i don't know if that's
a brag or really it's a
it's a knock on you you had the inside
he took the action he
well i don't know i don't that's true
that's true i mean yeah uh i'm just
talking [__]
but
so i think you were going to kind of ask
him something like how much did you put
in to start this basically how much of
your money did you did you have to cede
into making a venture like this happen
yeah so i put in close to 100k to make
this happen
um and some portion of that was a loan
that that i got out uh
just as like revenue started to come in
but yeah it was about 100k has been up
not a lot that's great no yeah it's not
a crazy thing that's a weekend for sam
thank you um i feel
i feel like um i feel like uh like it
okay so if you're telling me you could
start this with a hundred grand and how
many hours a week are you working on
this
uh to get it spun up i mean it was much
more like
hiring the right contractors and people
so it was five
ten maybe okay i feel like there's a
world where this like
let's be conservative i feel like
there's a like this is very clearly a 10
million
a year thing that makes 2 million in
profit right like like
it could definitely be way bigger but i
feel like that's a relatively light i'd
be disappointed
forward and hit that mark right that's
kind of what you're saying yeah yeah
that would happen
expectations at least yeah so right like
and let's give me
let's give it six years to do that let's
go let's grow slow uh i feel like that's
like a
it's pretty sure fire away you're going
to get that would you you agree
uh yeah i certainly do and so if that
was the case
right a dc brand like that can sell for
like 1x revenue
let's say so you could turn 100k
investment
and let's call it even 20 hours a week
for
for a year to spin it up to you you
turned 100k
into basically you know 10 million bucks
worth of
of total equity value in term in terms
of the company in that case
i don't even think it'll take six years
i think that's two two years yeah i'm
being like
ultra yeah i agree um but yeah i mean
that's the basic thing
where are the other opportunities in the
space that you when you're researching
yeah i mean i there's a ton right like i
think that we're at this generational
shift where people you know 10 years ago
everyone was like let's go out maybe
this is just me getting older i don't
know but
all of my friends were like let's go out
to the bars and get really drunk
now all my friends are like let's have
one glass of wine and then like
have a great long dinner and or try you
know or not drink it all right
and instead young people i don't young
people i don't think drink
yeah it's
it's becoming much more common
shockingly that's what i'm saying like
the gen z
is like like uh it's not as common like
when
the second i could drive have you heard
sam's gen z
analysis that he does is his trends
analysis on gen z
he's like they don't have sex they don't
drink it they're depressed
but they're really cool looking what do
you see what do you call them yeah
they're really cool
they got they got nice teeth they always
wear vans
and they like they always have like
proper fittings what color do they like
what do i say like red or millennials
you can
have like a really sweeping
generalization for that it's like the
truth
like they all have like sick ass
haircuts um
it's true they all got like amazing i
mean
cut right now he's looking he's looking
gen z dude the young people
i'm saying they they don't they don't
have they don't have a lot of sex not
nearly as much as before and they just
even with all that teeth and hair they
can't they're not having sex what's
going on
dude i don't know well testosterone is
down 50
over the last like 40 years that's right
yeah maybe that's it it's like
this is something there's something
going on here and they also don't like
alcohol like it's a health thing
or i don't know what it is but they
don't drink yeah
i mean i i honestly think one of the
reasons i'm bullish on the non-ox space
is like
we're getting to the point where they're
just better drugs
like if people want to you know alter
their state of consciousness
i'm seeing a lot more friends that are
like opting into cannabis or ketamine or
some of the you know psychedelics or
some of these other things
that don't give you the hangover don't
give you the 30 extra pounds over a year
of heavy drinking like
i just think people are opting for for
different sorts of compounds different
heights to give them the experience they
want
yeah exactly i tried that recess drink
you guys tried that the
yeah kind of like carbonated drink great
branding
amazing branding i would say drink
tastes like [__] and didn't do anything
so i was like well
i'm out on that one but i love the idea
of it i kind of wish it
if we just if they just put lacroix in
that can i'd feel amazing i'd be like
yeah this is the best this is the future
uh but instead you know they tried their
own thing um what are some businesses
that
you're like you mentioned testosterone
we invested in this testosterone
replacement company because we were like
that same which one uh
it's called peak or they're just
rebranding to hone but
basically it's at home direct consumer
you know testing for your t levels and
then when you get tested and it's if
it's low
you're they'll there's like a
telemedicine doctor who will be like hey
by the way if you want this to go up you
know like
there are some solutions that we can
offer you basically they have their own
you've not heard of that justin i've
heard of trt i didn't i didn't heard of
like peak or home it's basically right
it's like
trt i'm ready to throw six letters yeah
you don't believe in it it's real yeah
yeah
maybe that's not a well said thing but i
tend to think that some of these things
it's like
you know your testosterone levels are
low it's like okay the reason that
they're low is some
inputs from your environment are not
healthy and so rather than trying to fix
the symptom like you should try and fix
the environment but what are the biggest
inputs you can change to to boost
testosterone from your opinion
i i think diet sleep uh in like
inflammation
and then also trying to cut out like
endocrine disrupting hormones
uh which are i think like a horrifying
thing that not a lot of people are
talking about
what does that talk about so different
uh plastics compounds like you've heard
of like bpa-free and all these sorts of
things
um the whole class of something called
phthalates which is p h t
p t h l a t e s um
that effectively have like a really
strong
negative impact on one's testosterone
ones like
endocrine and hormonal systems and
they're that are in like
everything they're so avoiding like or
they're from something else
uh yeah a lot of plastics yeah um so
these are like synthetic materials that
are just in like
water plastics food packaging uh creams
that you use like they're all they're
they're everywhere so what's something
you do lifestyle wise that i'd be like
dude why are you doing that um like i
went to my friend's house one time and
he instead of using toothpaste he was
like
he dipped his toothbrush in like this
powder and started brushing his teeth i
was like
hey man what the [__] is that because
he's always like three steps ahead in
health
and like products and so any at first i
used to judge him and now i'm like oh
am i killing myself by using toothpaste
should i be using this powder [__] and
like
you know what are those what would yours
be can i guess justin can i get yeah i
guess
um do you use a microwave no no
i didn't think okay um yeah
but like you go out of your way to not
use a microwave right yeah yeah
okay do you um you definitely only have
glass
tupperware correct yeah for sure um what
else is there
uh um do you uh
i i've got a few more i i've got a few
more i can peg you but you're telling me
i got this like 19 step home water
filtration thing installed at my house
that's like the metal one
it's like 25 feet tall and in this
outside it's insane
it's outdoors uh the plumbers yeah yeah
they they're
at every step so there's one other sink
there's one outside that like filtered
all the home water
the guys came in to install it they're
like we have never seen anyone install
something like this um but yeah so i
have that set up
that i just recently got the tupperware
stuff uh pretty
diet cautious in general um are you
super ripped i can't see
your neck up here are you like okay no
he's lean
yeah you're lean you're like ten percent
body fat right i'll send you a p-spot
photo
yeah i need it i need to pee well i've
seen you without a shirt like you're not
like uh
like huge but you're like you look like
a like a
soccer player right who's more fit
you're a justin
uh it depends on what we're talking
about who is
do you aspire more for your body or for
his body go
uh i would pref right now i prefer to be
leaner and skinnier so i'm trying to
lose fat and look a little bit more like
his body all right great all right so
you have the insane water filtration
system and what is that by the way
what's the name of it
uh it is called the radiant life i think
but there's another one john do you saw
the people
i i do i have a song do you like a
definite song in my backyard is it
infrared or is it uh
no it's the uh yeah it's like the the
hot stone one
and like red lights on your toes or
something in the morning what do you
what do you do anything with any kind of
light uv
anything no i try to get outside i mean
it this is one of those things that i
think is like
there's some people that i think over
optimize where they're like oh i need
more light exposure so i'm going to stay
inside
and like shine red light on my stuff and
i'm like just
outside do you only use zero drop
shoes no what is that i did for a while
i just didn't really what is a zero drop
shoe
basically shoes with no heel yeah most
shoes have some type of
uh like yeah but like a lot of people
believe that that ruins your achilles
and hurts your calves
um and a bunch and ruins your posture um
do you um
uh do you only eat meat from salt and
thyme
i try to when i can it's the best meat
in austin for sure where do you get your
meat from
uh so i now i eat most of my meat is
from salt and time
or stuff that i've hunted or a friend
has hunted
i love it this is awesome okay great did
we miss any other ones any other good
uh like sort of self i don't what do we
even call these uh
well look i i think what we're teasing
but there is truth in this like guys who
are on the cutting edge
and things that we joke and laugh at i
believe that's going to be normal
uh you know like totally like i remember
like years ago i
i got into this hobby uh about raw denim
which is like a
at the time it was like super nerdy and
everyone made fun of me and
it didn't get entirely mainstream but a
little bit mainstream it got quite uh
popular um and and that was um that's
kind of like what we're talking about
here so like
i remember years ago people were talking
about ayahuasca and i was like what the
[__] is that and now like i know so many
people that are doing this stuff
so totally uh oh and dan said you use
non-stick pans you definitely you don't
use non-stick pans for sure i could tell
that
yeah i use a ceramic set or cast iron
yeah
yeah that that's an easy one but anyway
go ahead what was the answer were you
gonna are there any other things that we
can learn from how you live
yeah i mean i i think that like cutting
out things that are causes of
inflammation
or the obvious ones it's like don't
microwave stuff in plastic
try and like buy stuff that is overly
not overly processed and packaged
uh and i think actually like avoiding
vegetable oils is a tremendous
tremendous thing that like you said
about raw denim or ayahuasca
um you know five years from now 10 years
from now
a lot of people are going to be way more
conscious about vegetable oils and
the damage that they specifically like
compound called linoleic acid in there
um that the damage that does to like
your inflammation what will they use
instead olive oil or peanut oil or
yeah i mean hopefully olive oil avocado
oil animal fats lard ghee butter
stuff like that coconut oil do you want
to talk about uh you wanna talk about
one or two more of these
sean or what uh yeah let's do let's do
you pick you pick the topic let's do one
more topic
oh i know i was going to ask you really
quick all these things that you're doing
there's like no microwave all this stuff
do you actually feel a difference or um
is it is it like these all long term or
is there any short term pleasure and
that i can get out of these like do you
feel different
yeah so i the way that i think about
this is like from a baseline standpoint
uh you know if you if you have a pretty
high baseline like imagine you're super
strong
it's going to be really hard for you to
notice if you're a bodybuilder
if you're putting on like one percent
you know two pounds of muscle or
something if you already
if you're already like weighing 225 um
so
i think that i have a pretty high like
health baseline and so a lot of these
things are more preventative and not
like
oh my god i feel amazing uh you know
whereas i felt like [__] the other day
but for i think the average person like
if your baseline is relatively low
you want to lose like or average you
want to lose weight you're not sleeping
well
um you know your stress hormones are all
over the place a lot of these
interventions like you'll feel a
material difference after like
20 or 30 days i think there's a world to
build like a wire cutter version of this
so for example like you're saying a lot
of stuff and my friend my best friend
jack is into all this stuff and
and when i stay at his house and i visit
him and so that's how i like i see how
he lives
and jack's really honest and i'll say he
takes all these supplements i go do any
of these do anything and he goes no
like i don't feel any different um and
like a guy like you i imagine you
actually care about longevity
and also you just like to tinker and you
like trying gadgets you know i like
training gadgets as well i just want to
like see the latest and greatest it's
fun to experiment
i would love but but the issue is is
that someone like you like
or not you but some of the folks in your
world like
they can get a little woo-woo and i'm
like i don't know if they're like
talking about [__] crystals or if
this is actually gonna make a difference
in my life it's really hard to know
like uh if like this actually truly is
meaningful
i wish and i went to peter peter atiya's
blog about this as well to learn about
fitness and he talks about so much stuff
about fitness and diet and i'm like
just give me the if you just do this
life will be a little bit better
and you're 80 there yeah i think there's
a big opportunity for that i think that
one of the problems is like if you're an
influencer you're going to get way more
attention
and interest from people when you talk
about butthole sunning
than you are about like eat a healthy
diet you know what i mean
like yeah totally like i think that's
the point
what's that mean same thing
you've never seen this article the same
it went like super viral basically i'll
send you
a bunch of naked people we're going out
like they're tanning but then they raise
their legs above their heads so that the
sun goes directly into their butt
and they're like you know never felt
better you know
the sun's energy right into your fourth
eye do we want to go over
one more thing or two more things what
do you want to do
it's your call well we can't end on
butthole somebody's yeah i guess i guess
that will probably leave for bad taste
so i've got an interesting you you have
something interesting
and i want to so i've got a friend named
nick you know nick ray i bet
and nick um he he jokes about it but
he's being serious
he matches with girls on tinder or
whatever app he uses
and he calls them for a pre-screening
for a date he's like let's just talk to
each other
because he's nick's uh he just wants to
get down to business like do we want to
date or not
and he calls them and one of the
questions he asks sean right away is
what's your credit history or
uh like do you have debt um and
odd here justin has he goes i think i
could create a dating app that based off
your credit card history
um but this wasn't just to be clear it's
not your credit rating he's talking
about not like i only want a very
rich credit worthy people it's more like
if i know what you're going to be rich
or whatever what he's saying is i want
to look at your purchase history
basically
the stuff you buy if you shop at whole
foods if you go to the gym if you don't
whatever
you go to the bar you ring up a bill
that'll tell us how compatible we are
that was your idea
yeah exactly and are you dating right
now are you single
uh i am recently engaged personally and
if you matched you and your fiancee's
bills up before you got engaged would
would you have been a good match great
fit great fit yeah for sure
i think that like where you spend your
resources tells a lot about
someone that a hinge profile doesn't and
so i suspect if like
you were to say hey we are matching the
two of you up because you spend an
absurd amount of your income
at this like weird butcher shop in
austin or
at whole foods like we're probably going
to get along you know or at least have a
higher odds of doing that
from a lifestyle compatibility
standpoint than than hinge does you know
sam what do you think all right let's do
yeah i mean
i mean i i think no this would work i
think this is one of those things that
people say i think we're gonna give that
one a no but
i enjoy that you said it yeah like i
think my opinion is like
when it comes to dating um you really
just like
you want to optimize for getting laid
quickly i think like regardless if
that's what people admit or not but like
they just want to get to like
date one so they can get in bed uh for
step two
and i think that really people like they
say they like so um
uh when we had our roommate matching app
i don't know if you could actually vouch
for if
you saw this on your end people said
they wanted this they wanted that they
wanted this
and then they would meet someone and
they're like nah [__] it like i'll just
do it
uh right like and so i think the same
with dating you say you want to do this
you want to do that but then if i
show you like a person who you just
think is attractive even though you had
all these rules
uh you're gonna say ah all right
whatever let's just do it yeah yeah
no i think that's probably true i think
this probably would be better as a like
matchmaking service than a broad-based
dating app right
and and then we'll let's let's wrap up
with the one that we've actually talked
about before about this automation
officer
yeah let's do it um basically i think
with the rise
of no code tools virtual assistants all
this sort of stuff
like i think the average company and we
do this at my company
could just be 30 more productive like we
we have basically one virtual assistant
hire for every two people that we have
that are on the team
and we give them like a training that's
like here's how to use virtual
assistants get all of the repetitive
stuff
off your plate and i just wish i could
hire someone to do that as a service
where like
he or she sits in product meetings or
marketing or logistics team
[__] and it's just like we're gonna
automate these five pieces
and just continually does that across
the company where did you learn that
from who
that's so so interesting to give va's to
every two people yeah uh i just started
doing it when we started the company
i think that's pretty amazing right how
did you
learn the how to how to manage a va what
you can use them for what you can where
did you learn that part
obviously but like what was the spark
yeah when i when i left um when i left
like
the company i was working with terry at
we got acquired and then i was kind of
like starting to do my own stuff on the
side
and was like okay i want to try and
scale myself uh to do more stuff on the
side so like
originally hired va is to help with
responding to airbnb requests
and then view me requests and then like
slowly got them more integrated into my
life
i love it and did you take a course or
something like where did you this
training that you have for for your
employees is that modeled off something
or what
uh no we we basically like we have some
internal documents that myself and other
people on the team have written up
around how to leverage virtual
assistants and we just do that
you should uh publish this yeah i feel
like that's i think
you're kind of like this you're not
dismissing this but you're kind of like
brushing over this i feel like that's
actually one of the more interesting
things that i've
learned today i think that's actually
pretty amazing i've had a lot of people
ask me for this and i actually suck at
using va's and don't really use them but
i know i should
uh and could do more and this is one of
if
i kind of like pinged the audience i was
like all right if i could teach you
anything that you think like what do you
think i could teach you that i know that
that you want to know and surprisingly
this was like number five on that list
and so i
plan to eventually a learn it myself and
better
so that i can like offer this others but
i was very surprised to see that on the
top list
of things people wanted to learn that
they felt like
they were just curious about and they
felt that there was value there but they
didn't know how to unlock it
that's interesting yeah i mean maybe
this is something that i should publish
at some point
and i don't know how much do you what
what how much budget do you allocate is
it like two grand a month per two people
or what
we yeah we probably
about that like call it like 10-ish
grand across like the whole company
so you what do you guys have you have 20
people we have 33.
dude that's pretty sick how you've kept
it like relatively small for i
yeah i have no intel i would imagine
your revenue
is in the 60 million range if i had to
guess
um and that's pretty a lean mean team
for how value how much value that is
definitely and i think the va piece is a
big part of it like we just have a very
efficient team that's pretty focused on
getting stuff done that they uniquely
can do and the va's are super helpful
with the rest
well dude this is sick man i i can't see
sean's face i can't see where he's going
yeah my camera
overheats uh this is a recurring problem
i moved it all i moved my whole setup
inside for this but then i also got two
babies inside so i thought all right
do i want to risk babies crying or my
camera over here
guaranteed camera overheat and i chose
the camera
justin do you want to promote yourself
where do you want where do you want
people to go to i
a lot of people are gonna listen to this
so uh what your.com your twitter where
are you gonna what are you gonna pin
yeah so probably my twitter i'm at jw
mares uh or you know my website
justinmers.com i have a monthly
newsletter that i send out
where i talk about various things i
think about health business and whatever
else is kind of on my mind
um that seems like people like i think
sam you like it too right
yeah i'm looking at your stuff now i'm a
subscriber i get your it's not a sub
stack it's just a blog right
uh yeah but i have a monthly newsletter
that is on substance but
yeah that's right i i get your emails in
my uh thing
or in my email and i i message you about
it i'm like oh i just saw your airbnb
thing i'm
because i actually want to do that i
think that's sick i think that'd be a
great way to finance
uh like a a pretty large bit of land i
think that's fun
i went go i went shooting i went to this
place out in texas where you
shoot guns and then afterwards you go
and ride atvs and it was like i was in
heaven i was like
this is just the most fun i could
possibly have i have to go and buy a
place so i can do this all the time
it's awesome uh what are you gonna say
sean uh i was gonna say justin i gotta
give you the compliment i'll give
your blog is that your your content is
so good it made me question i was like
is this guy
really like a good entrepreneur or is
this like because like usually
like there's some people who are truly
great at putting out content
and truly great at doing actually like
walking the walk and doing the doing the
business side have actually done it
themselves they're not just like
studying others and writing content but
often what you'll find is that
people are good at one i know a bunch of
amazing business people who don't want
to or suck at creating content
and i know some great content people
that i'm like once i meet them i'm like
oh you've this is what this is your
business you've never done a business
outside of
this content business and uh so then
when i found out that you were good at
both i was like okay
you know props to you for both but
that's how good the content was that it
made me
made me do the research and say is this
is this guy legit or what
i appreciate that i'm definitely not
good at like the content business side
of things
or posting frequently but i i like
really enjoy putting it out gonna do
this
yeah you've been doing it for years i'm
looking at your site now i'm reading
your 2020 review
i just clicked off central athlete
because you talked about central athlete
i mean it seems like you've been doing
this for years so i mean that's
consistent
definitely i like it but in small doses
not as a full-time thing
all right great we should wrap it up um
dude thanks for coming on this was fun
yeah you're like a perfect fit for like
the type of audience that we have
they're going to love
i think the content that you uh the
ideas and stuff you shared so that was
great
thank you thanks for having me on guys
this is fun
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
never looking back